we don't trust people to follow rules we
trust people to know when to break them
right the rules are there for normal
operation
and they're perfectly valid like it's
good to have
sides on the sandbox otherwise the sand
just pours out right so the
the rules give guidance there's nothing
wrong with policies and rules and things
like that but there
but but their guidance and if something
goes wrong
we have to find out why it went wrong
right so um
i've told this story a bunch of times so
you can interrupt me if you know it um
true story two true stories about um
that happened in the air force
the air force has a very very simple
rule um
do not fly into iranian airspace
really easy right so there was a kc-135
tanker that was flying in circles
just in a holding pattern in case
someone needs gas in this case someone
needs them
right and the crew accidentally drifted
into iranian airspace
it sets off all kinds of alarm bells
right not good
completely different incident unrelated
different time another case kc-135 just
coincidentally
was doing the same thing they were they
were doing uh
donuts um in case somebody needed them
and a fighter jet
called bingo which means they ran out of
gas they need gas
and the crew made some calculations
and they wanted to get to him as quickly
as possible because he's out of gas and
the quickest way to get to him
was to slice through iranian airspace
now on paper they both broke the same
rule they should both be punished
equally and they should both be
uh they should both be punished right
the reality is only one of those crews
was punished
the ones that were idiots but the crew
that made the decision to cut through
the space
knowing full well that it was against
the rules knowing full well that they
could get in trouble
and it would accept the punishment if it
happened
weren't punished because context matters
so the question is is why is somebody
late three times in a row
is it because they live far away because
they're taking care of their sick mother
and they're and they've been struggling
to get
the bus every day because the rebus has
been you know
is it because they're a single parent
and they're struggling to get the kids
out
um for uh uh in the morning to school
or is it because they overslept because
they're lazy or because they went
partying the night before
and they and they missed their job and
they and you're a pushover so whatever
they just take advantage of you
i don't know could be one of those you
know
um and the question is is
we don't want them to be late but we
understand that they're struggling
so how do we find a middle ground how i
you cannot be late anymore but i
understand that you're struggling
because you can't get the kids out of
school
let's work together to see how we can
make this work can we change your shift
what works for you like let's work
together to make this work
you know context matters versus
you know you know that this is giving
you some nonsense excuses something
you're like listen
take some accountability and that's a
different conversation you know
but but to immediately dismiss someone
because they missed they were late three
times to me
that that seems like lazy leisure lazy
leadership lazy leaders rely on the
rules